show that the equation X minus e to the
negative x equals zero has exactly one
root and that this roots x naught
satisfies this inequality zero and less
than X naught less than one okay so
let's talk about what we did well first
okay to show that there's exactly one
root for this and that it has to be
between here a lot of you saw I mean
maybe use your reading time you looked
in part two you're like oh this is one
of those approximation things right
so which piece of knowledge can we use
to show that there's going to be a root
between here and here which piece of a
lot of you got this question what did
you use say it again louder area okay
the discriminant would be something that
I could use to find where there are
solutions but discriminates only work
with very certain kinds of equations
what kinds of equations our discriminant
useful for quadratic equations
unfortunately in this particular case
that's not gonna be so handy so again I
want you to think think about this value
and think about this value if there's a
root between there right then what's
going to happen between these two values
there's a change inside there's a change
in sign either you go from positive to
negative or negative to positive so all
you had to do and most of you were fine
with this is just evaluate this at each
of these values right and then you've
got a negative for one you've got a
positive for other it's a continuous
function so somewhere in between it's
not going to do something like this I'm
negative down here and then I've got a
hole and then now I'm positive okay it's
actually continuous it's going to do
something more like this
so somewhere in between here it's going
to cross that's what we mean by an x
intercept look at the question again
okay because what we missed here had to
do with the wording of the question sure
that the equation ba-ba-ba-ba-ba has
exactly one root and that satisfies this
inequality okay so if we've tested this
value on this value we have shown that
it crosses the axis but how many times
have we shown that it crosses the axis
and if we've only tested on the ends we
actually don't know how many times it
crosses the axis yeah I drew it like
this but it could just as easily have
done something like this there we go
I mean that would be weird and strange
but there's nothing impossible about it
so just because I go from negative to
positive or vice-versa that doesn't mean
there is what's the word what's the key
word that makes this different have a
look read the question
as shown there's a root but haven't
shown days I had it I mentioned is
exactly one root I've shown that this
there's a root somewhere but there might
be others so what could I do
to show that there's only one if there's
exactly one I gave you a clue right at
the beginning when I talked about the
common thread that all these questions
had I could have graphed it now this
admittedly takes a bit more thinking so
it's not just as simple as I've got two
things just graph them okay how do you
even what would you do with a graph to
actually show this well this is trickier
I don't really know what that thing
looks like off the top of my head if you
were extension to students I would
expect you to I would train you in the
techniques to be able to work out what
that is using this fancy technique
called subtraction of ordinates but you
guys don't know that yet so what am I
supposed to do with that you could go
and do some calculus we can find
stationary points etc but this is to my
question and I've already done enough
where to get at least one of those marks
what's a simple way that I could work
with this thing and you graph aha okay
so let's come down here right so
following on you with your working see
how in question two when you see an
equation on this side and that side all
that means is look at them independently
and find where they intersect I can
rewrite this in such a way to make it
exactly the same kind of question by
adding e to the negative x to both sides
okay if I know what that looks like and
I know what that looks like and that's
really easy to graph so let's quickly do
that
we'll do the simple one first what can
you told me about y equals x I know
you've been on some weeks of your tears
but I'm not letting you get away with
that what do we know about the graph of
y equals x it's a it's a linear graph
where where does it go through it goes
through the origin and it's got a
gradient of 1 I'll give you that one for
free ok there's X ok we need to think a
little bit more about this guy so it's
an exponential but what can you tell me
about it
most Exponential's start low and then
they go high right like exponential
growth yeah but this one doesn't how do
I know yeah this negative it's applied
through the X the X is a horizontal
thing so the negative is a horizontal
reflection right so this is the graph
that I'm getting I'm satisfied with that
I've got some values here there we go ok
now is that enough of an argument to
show what I was trying to prove look
back at the question back of what we've
been asked to prove is that enough of a
proof for us
what do you think
hmm sad again
I want to show that I you know there's a
point of intersection between here and
here but I want to show there's only one
and when you have a look at this graph
there's something I'm missing off here
I've got an asymptote down here so this
guy's never going to come back up either
negative x has no stationary point no
exponential curve does it's never going
to whip back up to try and catch up with
y equals x you can see over here they're
diverging there is one and only one
solution that is totally valid working
everything on their graph is that is
there that's demonstrates what I need
that there's only one solution and then
I would do my test to show that the one
solution happens between here and here
zero and one that make sense graph
please it wouldn't have taken you long
and there was the mark really easier one
to get to I'm not going to go on to part
two of that because I think once you got
to there you're like Oh Newton's method
it kicks in in some ways that makes part
one harder than Part two part two you're
like I have an algorithm for this I can
just go through the steps part one you
need to actually think a little bit